[MUSIC PLAYING]
LUCY D'AGOSTINO MCGOWAN: Hi.
I'm Lucy D'Agostino McGowan.
And I'm excited to talk
to you about designing
randomized studies using shiny.
You can find me on Twitter
@LucyStats and you can find
these slides at
lucymcgowan.com/talk.
So the work I'm
going to be talking
about today was done in
collaboration with students
in my data science lab at
Wake Forest University,
in particular Jonathan
Trattner and Nuri Park.
And you can find some
of our other projects
at dmds.lucymcgowan.com.
OK.
So I'm going to show you
four ways we can leverage
the power of Shiny to help
streamline our randomized study
design via informed
consent, randomization,
collecting demographics, and
incorporating learnr modules.
So informed consent: informed
consent is a common process
when involving human
subjects in a trial.
Often you hand people a piece of
paper and they either say that
they agree to be in a
study or they don't.
And so instead of
that, we can actually
have the entire
process completed
online from the comfort of
your participants' browsers.
And so we're basically going
to leverage Shiny, such
that if the user consents,
they're sent to the study.
And if they don't, then they're
sent back to the home page.
And so in Shiny, we often work
with two components: the user
interface--
what the user sees--
and the server--
what runs behind
the scenes in R.
And so here's some
code for the user
interface to be able to
incorporate the consent here.
And so first you can incorporate
the consent text via an HTML
document for example.
And then you can use an
actionButton function
to create a nice
action button that
will either send the participant
to the study, if they agree,
or back to the home page if not.
So on the server
side, we need to check
whether the user
clicked yes or no
and then send them
somewhere accordingly.
Until this function will check.
If the user clicked
yes, and if they did,
it's going to open a new window
and send them to the link.
I'm doing this using renderUI.
So I need to make sure to update
the user interface with that UI
output, so that this
actually works.
And so that's what
this is doing here.
This uiOutput and
then open_study
was the ID that I gave
that output in the server.
So now that will actually
send them to the link.
So one of the coolest things
about using Shiny for this
is that it gives you the power
of R from the web browser.
So we can actually
randomize participants
at the time of consent.
So it basically really
streamlines that process.
So we just need to update the
server a little bit to do that.
And so essentially
what I've done here
is, I've added a coin
flip to determine
which group the
participant should be in,
and then they're sent to a
different link accordingly.
So we're developing
a package in R
that does this and a
few other neat features
like generates user IDs, saves
a randomization lists, allows
for unique links for
users, et cetera.
It's very much under development
but you can find it on GitHub
at jdtrat/taskdesignr.
OK.
So now that we
randomized folks, let's
collect some demographics.
So we have another package
called shinysurveys,
that can help with this.
And this one actually is
almost ready for prime time.
So I encourage you to try it.
You can install it from
GitHub at jdtrat/shinysurveys.
And so basically what this
package allows you to do
is it lets you pass the data
frame with questions, options,
input types,
dependencies, et cetera.
And a nice Shiny
questionnaire is
going to be generated for you
that can then be incorporated
in your application.
And so in R, it's as easy
as just loading the package
and then using the surveyOutput
function in the user interface,
passing the data frame
with your questions in it.
And so here my data
frame is called d.
And then using renderSurvey
in the server function
and you also will pass
it that same data frame.
And this will automatically
generate a nice survey.
It'll look something
like this, where
it has the questions as well as
the different places to input.
You can have required questions
with those little stars.
You can also have dependencies.
For example, if the
answer a certain way,
then new questions can
pop up accordingly.
So finally all of this
can be incorporated
in commonly used shiny
tools like learnr modules.
So for example,
learnr modules can
record all of the
user's input data, which
can be great for a study.
And you can stick the user
IDs generated from the
taskdesignr package in here.
And then you can save this
data with the unique ID
that can be linked to
the demographic data
for later analysis.
So that's all.
You can find me
@LucyStats on Twitter.
Thank you so much.